peu
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir girard bonsoir de
nouveaux trucs aujourd'hui le premier
l'évasion d'houdini 300 enfants
d'ailleurs tous nos cadres nos candidats
ont les mains attachées par gérard est
notre deuxième truc lui aussi vaut 300
francs c'est le truc de monsieur lecerf
épicier de paris la bouteille généreuse
je vous présente
chers amis nos six nouveaux candidats
cinq messieurs pourri dame candidat
numéro 1
tomassi grand-fort-philippe candidat
numéro des sujets gasp un candidat
numéro 3 sur wii rouge de grenoble
candidat numéro 4 et la nourrit de
mantes-la-jolie candidat numéro 5 même
franceschi de coignières et candidat
numéro 6 et la rose de paris 300 francs
notre premier truc l'évasion d'houdini
[Musique]
voici une célèbre évasion d'houdini avec
un foulard demandé à un ami de vous
tendre ses bras de façon à placer autour
des poignets
le foulard ainsi il est bien attaché
encore un noeud maintenant il ne peut
plus écarté ses bras pleins c'est une
corde comme ceci est dans cette position
comment peut-il s'échapper sans que je
lâche les extrémités de la corde
quel est le truc et vous avez trouvé un
truc bouquet d'attaché monsieur tomasi
regardez bien 300 francs notre premier
truc une question posée à gérard oui
vous avez une idée
est-ce que se croiser est-ce qu'on se
croise à tout comme je suis attendait
venez venez venez je n'ai pas très bien
compris
prenez par la tension au micro voilà
très bien alors qu'est ce que voulait
faire
non non non mais chez ce n'est pas ça on
va c'était amusant comme position
attention votre micro à cela
monsieur les numéros des messieurs
gaspard est ce que
est-ce que je peux tirer ah oui mais
vous vous allait entraîner la corde si
je la lâche mais ce n'est pas la
solution monsieur je pense aussi le
foulard à non non non il ne faut pas
défaire le foulard moi je vous êtes très
bien comme ça ça va très bien sous la
poigne et monsieur genevois candidat
numéro 3 monsieur guy roux et du rouge
et or dans pardon c'est guy rougier
pardon excusez moi rien mangé à midi
pour entier est accompagné dans la tâche
et un poignet alors dans l'émail et sans
comme ça alors l'accord dans le nez au
milieu des messieurs venez essayer parce
que vous avez peut-être une idée qui
marche on s'en rend pas compte là on va
essayer de tenir placez-vous par là
attendez vous allez le faire
voilà vous allez faire tonner je passe
la corde à l'intérieur voilà messieurs
vous faites ce que vous voulez au bout
du chemin
non non non non
non là vous trichez la barre de fer
couleurs je voulais faire je crois qu'on
fait un e dans le la corde
c'est à dire mais à la vie on l'a fait
en deux et on fait un nul c'est à dire
en l'opt et en dehors on ne rentre pas
la donne et monsieur jeu à vous rouliez
au départ on triche
ah non non non non la corde est vraiment
derrière monsieur dans les bras oui oui
vous réfléchissez là mais ça vous donne
pas d'idées c'est à dire qu'il est
rentré pas là au début
non non on passe l'accord vraiment sonné
venez venez parce que tant que je
n'aurai pas fait je vous rendrai pas
compte voilà elle est comme ça vraiment
au départ on ne triche pas oui ça ne
sera pas à 100 par oui madame madame
candidat numéro 5 est ce qu'on dit c'est
autre chose que la corde la normale
on utilise rien d'autre
la disposition des masques sanaa ah oui
c'est une question madame de position de
musique sens du client
demain je peut-être pas des mains c'est
peut-être des doigts ou glisser quelques
choses de manières madame vous avez une
solution pressé non non non candidat
numéro 6 monsieur larose est ce que la
corde doit passer entre les deux mains
l'évasion au oui monsieur
pas tous devaient donner vais essayer et
peut-être une idée on n'est pas ici cher
monsieur face à nos amis que tout le
monde voit bien voilà la corde et là
j'arrive à attraper oui oui monsieur en
attendez vous avez attrapé d'accord oui
et maintenant on avait passé et voilà
monsieur que vous avez gagné
on recommence alors maintenant monsieur
l'a compris va leur faire c'est presque
un mouvement professionnel mais il va
vous le montre en détail la corde est
ici d'employer les poignées sont bien
attachés recommencer monsieur voilà vous
accrocher avec les doigts d'accord vous
échangez très facile maintenant faites
le de l'autre côté que tout le monde
voit bien voilà est automatiquement
évidemment moi je ne lâche rien mais la
cote passer dégagé monsieur vous avez
gagné
bravo vous avez gagné 300 francs bravo
bravo notre deuxième truc et c'est à ce
truc appartient à monsieur le sert qui
est épicier à paris où trois enfants
la bouteille généreuse monsieur le surf
et épiciers et un truc à nous proposer
voici une bouteille de vin normal elle
est normale
ah oui c'est du solide
voilà comment verser le vin sans
débouchés la bouteille
cherchez bien le truc de monsieur le
surf candidats libéraux à monsieur
tomasi vous aimez le vin produit repas
le bougeant à monsieur je suis obligé de
respecter les mots et la pensée de
monsieur le cf qui nous indique le
groupe il s'agit de faire couler le vin
sans débouchés la bouteille donc on ne
retire pas le beau chant danse ou
cultivées est ce que la qualité
la qualité du vin et l'importance et du
port tous et du beaujolais
ah oui là je reconnais vos origines mais
vous êtes portugais d'origine
c'est pour ça vous nous faites une
petite publicité pour le pays en plus
que vous avez raison monsieur de toute
façon je dois vous faire n'a aucune
importance que quel que soit le liquide
c'est ce que vous vouliez dire monsieur
que ce soit de l'alcool blanc de l'eau
on a cinq bouteilles de vin parce que
c'est coloré et puis que j'ai bien
français parce que j'y pense j'ai pensé
comme le porto il à + 2 degrés oui
rognon la bouteille puis avec la
pression de boeing le bouchon il sort
tout seul après oui mais ça rime à sa
table pour comme le jean bart oui c'est
pour n'importe quelle bouteille est sans
danger alors que dans votre principe si
ça éclate exposé ce n'est pas cela
candidat numéro 3 une question à poser
oui moi je pense est née des aulnes et à
travers ça où on aura yeoh l'emportent
au dessus de la bouteille
on commence à le taper la bouteille le
bouchant il sort tout seul ah oui mais
le truc de monsieur serge c'est sans
débouchés la bouteille donc sans retirer
le bouchon un pardon c'est sans retirer
le bouchon candidats libéraux 4t ce
cancer ii
du commun qui colle à vous de tirer le
liquide de parts par une conduite en
poule une seringue sera non monsieur il
ne s'agit pas d'envoyer une seringue
franceschi notre seule candidate
est-ce que l'enfance le bouchon
carrément oui madame venez venez c'est
le principe quand on débouche une
bouteille que l'on n'arrive pas à la
débauche si on en croit le bouchonner
par ici mais voilà
c'est l'astuce qui nous a été proposé
par monsieur le cf vous n'avez trouvé
très rapidement on aurait pu durer
d'ailleurs il aurait pu gagner 1500
francs mais là c'est vous qui gagnez car
voyez vous si vous prenez un tournevis
vous vous prenez quelque chose disons
assez fin pour enfoncer le bouchon en
passant le bouchon là est bien dans la
plupart des bouteilles sauf si vraiment
à bouchon on tient beaucoup au bord de
la bouteille et en s'y prenant avec
précaution y arriver écoutez madame au
lieu de le faire nous je crois que ce
serait plus sympathique de laisser
monsieur lecerf nous montrez lui même sa
solution nous le regardons pour vider
cette bouteille sans la débouchés il
suffit de prendre un tournevis
enfoncez vous changez aoued et dont tout
doucement ça marche très bien et voilà
juste une ou deux gouttes qui saute et
vous verser le liquide en france je vous
changer voilà
mais à votre santé monsieur le servent
enfin s'ils ne s'est pas demandé dans
l'est dans l'émission afin s'il est le
vin aigre bouchons c'est ce que disait
une spectatrice
je crois que ce n'est pas grave on ne
voit pas parce qu'il aurait déjà coups
de tournevis
bravo encore madame vous avez gagné 300
francs madame bravo vous rejoignez votre
place demain de nouveaux trucs cher
gérard le monde à l'envers il faudra 300
francs et la cigarette nous et trois
enfants également
regardez les bien un tour étrange avec
une boîte d'allumettes vide le tiroir et
place est retourné sur la table et
l'étui est placé de cette façon quel est
le truc qui permet d'inverser le tout
c'est à dire d'obtenir ceci sans toucher
aux tiroirs sans jamais toucher aux
tiroirs
cherchez bien une cigarette
avez vous déjà pensé à faire un noeud
avec une cigarette
nous allons essayer attention il faut
courber la cigarette est maintenant
doucement à casser sa part et des
vigiles mais pourtant on peut garder une
cigarette intacte tout en effectuant un
véritable noeud est classique ne mais il
faut connaître le truc
[Musique]